here's what changed in my life i had
given birth and the kids just gave me a
new direction you might want to grab the
tissues because jennifer lopez just
posted the sweetest tribute to her kids
on instagram and it's giving us all the
feels and max and emmy are getting so
big they're great they are they're so
big and so
amazing and happy the 52 year old mom of
two who shares twins max and emmy with
her ex marc anthony celebrated their
14th birthday on tuesday reposting this
sweet montage created by a fan account
to instagram
they just made me realize what was real
and what wasn't real and what was they
change a perspective on the world and
it's because of the love that you feel
for them it's so pure and unconditional
that it made me start re-examining
everything in my life
i don't know if it's the nicole
nordman's 2017 track slow down playing
in the background or jennifer talking
about the impact her kids have had on
her life or the clips of our kids
growing up but i'm feeling emotional and
so is j-lo i know i cry too people are
like is she crying i'm like almost every
night thank you
the triple threat captioned the post in
part quote you have taught me the true
meaning of life and have changed me
forever in the most amazing way and if
all that wasn't sweet enough she called
out her quote two coconuts writing 14
years ago has always symbolized for me
the first day of the rest of my life max
and lulu i will love you forever and
ever and ever
of course lulu is the longtime nickname
jen has for emmy and speaking of emmy
she seems to be following in her famous
momma's footsteps my mom's just like
she's amazing she's such a powerful
human being it's insane back in 2020 the
now teen joined her mom on stage for her
super bowl halftime performance
it was
insane that it happened cause you know
it's not very common for someone my age
to be on that stage it was
a crazy experience yeah it was really
great and in 2019 j.lo shared this video
of them on stage together in los angeles
[Applause]
she captioned the clip quote i can't
take it hashtag emmy
limitless
proud mama
and that that's emmy singing alicia keys
i mean
full body chills she's got her daddy's
voice she's amazing jennifer gushed over
her little girl's natural talent when it
caught up with her in 2019.
emmy always could say i remember when
she was in the crib when she was a baby
um she used to
be humming and like really humming to
herself and seeing and and mark would
say
she's singing
he's like it feels good to her it feels
good to her soul and to her like her
body
and as if all that weren't impressive
enough the following year emmy wrote a
children's book but what does jen think
about the potential of her little girl
going into show business here's what she
told e.t
only if she wants to it's a lot of work
and it's a lot of scrutiny and you
really put yourself out there listen if
she was gonna do it there's nothing i
could do to stop her yeah i know that
from being an artist myself nobody can
stop you from doing it
she's gonna do it she'll have to love
life she's she's gonna do it but you
know i would never you know push her in
any direction i will always help her as
much as i can and give her as much
counsel and advice as i can and mentor
in the best ways i know how to navigate
[Music]
you